Now let's dive into the project and continue developing the logic for our in-game cutscenes if you haven't already
Open the 205 start level from the content 205 maps folder in your content browser
So now that we're in the project
Let's go ahead and start adding the various components that we need to trigger our sequence and ultimately play it when the player
Hits something in this case. It's gonna be a trigger
So in the place actors panel, if you don't see that just go to window place actors
We're going to use this trigger box now
If you don't see trigger box just go to search classes and type in trigger
So why the trigger box somewhere on this platform here go ahead and move it up and we can scale it
Now if you want to be very precise in your details panel
Under the box extent. Let's just type in 150 150 150 and if I just deselect this so
We can select this actor by selecting a little icon here
But if you wanted to select it via the little kind of outline here, you notice that it's actually pretty small
So if we just select this take our line thickness to say something like 10 and maybe change the color to something like a hot pink
Now if I do select it, you'll see that it's a little bit easier to see and a little bit easier to select
Alright, perfect. All right. Now before we go on to this next step. I want to make a small disclaimer
So this next process as we're building out our functionality
We are going to put this functionality within our level blueprint
Now the thing that you want to keep in mind is that it's okay to put logic within your level blueprint. However for
Systems or things that are going to be used in multiple levels
So for example, we're building out this cutscene manager to where the player can step into a trigger box and trigger a cutscene
Assuming that our game is probably gonna have a lot of cutscenes
We don't want to put the logic within our level blueprint
And the reason being for that is again that logic within our level blueprint is only contained within the level itself
So if we have let's say hundreds of levels, well, we have to copy that code a hundred times over
All right. So the question that is probably begging to be asked is well, why don't we just do that now?
Well, the truth is that you will often place logic within your level blueprint for various reasons
So for this course, we're actually gonna be building that logic into our level blueprint and in the next course
we're gonna take that logic and we're actually going to put it into a
Self-contained actor a blueprint that can be used within any level. So for now, it's absolutely fine
This is okay to do
I just want you to keep in the back of your mind that
Putting a lot of logic or code for things that are going to be used in multiple levels
Within the level blueprint itself is not always the most advisable way to go about that
All right, let's go ahead and continue here. So with our trigger box
Selected I'm gonna go up to our kind of little three squares
I'm gonna do open level blueprint and this is going to open up the blueprint for our level again
Keep in mind. This is for the persistent world. This is this level only
So any code we put here we will have to copy over to a new level if that's how you want to build it
So within our level blueprint, I'm going to right-click and you'll see this add event for trigger box expand it out
Collision and add on actor begin overlap, and we'll do that compile and save
Now if you I'm actually gonna just deselect here in our level if you right-click and you don't see this on actor begin overlap
Reason for that is unreal has a nice little kind of handy quality of life feature that if you have the actor
Selected in your world and you right-click
You'll see that it will add some of the various different controls or different components. We can target within that blueprint
So again, if it's not selected right-click, you don't see it selected right-click you do
Alright, so now that we have our trigger box added to our level now, we wanted to actually do something
So in our slides here, you can see that
With our on actor begin overlap for our trigger box
we are going to play a movie a sequence player now in this case, we're going to target a
Sequence from the persistent level now quick note here. This says sequence 101. That's not the actual sequence
We'll using we'll jump over to the project here and actually put in the correct one that we're going to use
But the thing to take note here is because we're using our level blueprint
You'll notice that we have to target actors from the persistent level
So the actors that are in that level where that level blueprint exists
Alright, so now that we're back into our project
The first thing that we need to do is actually add our sequence to our level
So I'm gonna go down to our content browser here and in the sequence 2 0 5 0 0 the sequence folder
I'm gonna drag this sequence 2 0 5 start
I'm going to just kind of move this up and just basically kind of put it within our trigger box here
So I know that that's the sequence that I want to use
You don't have to have this sequence in the trigger box for it to play
In fact, this sequence could be off in some distant corner of the level
Position doesn't matter. Alright, so with that sequence 2 0 5 start selected
I'm gonna go ahead and just drag it into our world
So we have that actor gonna drag off of this and I'm gonna start typing play and we're looking for the play
Sequence player and you'll see that unreal automatically adds our little helper node there
So the translator to take the actor translated into a sequence player and that's going to be our target
let's go ahead and just drag off of this connect it hit compile and
Start and now what we should have is if I play
do this you notice there's my
Guy running and moving as soon as I hit that trigger box the sequence starts playing which is perfect
All right. I'm gonna go ahead and just stop that
It's off let's select our trigger box again F to frame and zoom in and we'll continue here
alright
so one of the issues that we have right now is if the sequence starts playing it will
play through and continue all the way to the end and then that trigger box still exists in our world and
We could theoretically run back into the trigger box and trigger the sequence again, which is not what we want, right?
We want this to be an in-game cutscene
We want it to play once the player to do something and that's it and be done
So if I go back to our slides here
You'll see that we need to add the second part of our logic to our level blueprint and that is disabling the trigger box
Collision now there's two options here that we have
You can use one you can use both doesn't matter. The first one is going to be
Setting the actor collision to false
So it means that it neat, you know
the player cannot trigger the collision again on this one or
We have this other option of just destroying the actor altogether. And essentially what happens behind the scenes is
once the sequence plays
It'll move on to the next event in our stack here
Which is destroy the actor and it will just delete it from the world making sure that it doesn't exist anymore
Now you could have both on here is absolutely fine just to be safe and we'll do that
The other thing to take note of here is that we need to make sure that we have our trigger box again from our persistent
Level set as the target for our collision. Let's jump back to our project
So within the level blueprint, I'm just gonna take this trigger box and drag off of it drag off of this pin here
And I'm going to just start typing
Collision and I believe this should be towards the top
We'll do this here. Keep looking or we can do
Set collision there to set actor enable collision
Excuse the target is the trigger box and new actor enable collision is set to false
Perfect drag off of this now if you want to keep your graph clean
Feel free to just double click add some reroute nodes
Do this just to make it look pretty
Perfect. Alright, so technically now if I just hit compile and save this should work
This may be all that you need maybe all that you want or
We can also just drag off of this guy right here and we can just do
Back to our slides here and we'll double check here
Destroy actor. Okay, so go here off of this one and just type in destroy
Destroy actor and then of course got to make sure that we hook it up it compile
Pro tip if you don't like your lines being all squirrely select the two nodes press Q and that will straighten
Perfect it start now if we were to go back in and test the event we could run through the trigger
It would trigger the sequence to a play and then as soon as the sequence is done
It will destroy that actor disable collision just to be safe and then we'll no longer be able to trigger it